helping you with malice was good for me
too
if you ever need me to help you with
malice again just give us a call I'll be
right there
I understand good and thanks for the
shag - that was great
hey everybody we got Constantine back we
jumped around - arrow flash hopefully
they'll make a joke about that destroyed
coffee shop on arrow sometime apparently
there's jittery franchises all over the
place I guess that's like the Starbucks
of Earth one too bad they didn't take
her to a belly burger but maybe they had
torn down that said they had like a
little one on arrow last season but
there are a couple of chain restaurants
the big stuff about this episode just in
addition to having Constantine in
general just a really cool thing is the
fact that they called Mallis out is a
demon but the thing is is that he wasn't
bound by the traditional rules that
buying magical creatures like when
Constantine tries to trap it in the
runes he's not trapped by that so that
means that he's either not a demon or
he's just a demon of a higher order that
just so powerful that you can't trap him
with traditional magic but the whole
thing you know number 10 is that they
learn his name you can't summon a demon
without using his name so to speak a
demon's name gives you a certain amount
of power over it you need to know its
true name because a lot of demons have
fake names so there might be some twist
with malice maybe he has a different
name or there's some secret behind him
all we know is that you should take him
at face value he is a legit demon so
based on some of the big twist at the
end of the episode - especially with the
warning that Constantine gave them about
Sarah I think they aren't trying to
deceive us I think he really is a demon
he's just an incredibly powerful one but
number 9 pick up in Star City that's
where the asylum is turns out emily is
actually damien darhk's daughter just a
much younger version of her when she's
first taken by Mallis so now we know why
she's drunk in the kool-aid because
there's this whole thing in the episode
about people being irredeemable maybe
you being able to save them they had
that whole subplot with kuwasa
vixen trying to redeem her but number
eight Constantine introduces himself to
the group you get all these nods to his
comic book backstory he even winks a
captain cold like he's coming on to him
because he's bisexual in the comics just
like Sarah lance's so obviously they got
it on during the episode it was really
funny but they tease a relationship with
Sarah and the woman
from the time bureau I think that part
of the Sarah character works best when
they don't try to pin her down to any
one particular relationship like number
seven that really funny moment where
they actually do have sex in the insane
asylum back during 1969 I was trying to
seduce you just one of the funnier
things about her character she's written
more like an Indiana Jones male type
character would be written you may have
also noticed the joke about Batman vs
Superman
during heat waves football game so while
he wants to do is watch his game water
[ __ ] stays in the freezer he was on
fire for that middle part of the episode
the goodbye with Captain Cold was a nice
scene but I still thought that it was
funnier when he was just yelling at
everybody to get out so that he could
watch his game but if you look at the
screen here one of the team's
abbreviations is BBS number six in order
to get back to the present they have
Sarah let herself be possessed by Mallis
so she goes to his dark realm again and
finds damien darhk's daughter even
though that was a bit of a misdirect and
they weren't able to change the future
outcome which I'll explain in a second
but if you didn't catch it the
flashbacks that she was having were from
when she was resurrected by Constantine
and then he references what happened
during arrow season four like they keep
going back to that moment when they were
last together like at the beginning of
the episode where he says I saved your
soul you owe me indefinitely so that
later number five they also flashback to
the end of arrow season 4 during that
big coffee shop I'm gonna call it a
jitters but they were trying to be
ambiguous about it because it was in
Star City not in Central City so even
though they were borrowing the exact
same jitters set that the flash people
use it was supposed to be in Star City
and I think it was all just because of
that moment they wanted to use on TV
where Oliver killed Amy and dark at the
end of season 4 just to trigger her
before damian darhk-- showed up so
jumping around in time there were
moments when they were in Central City
during the episode in moments when they
were in Star City but when they first go
to the Waverider where constantine is
walking on was there at the very
beginning of the episode there in
Central City but then when they take
Nora to the coffee shop later they're
back in Star City number four of course
was the current version of damian
darhk-- from present-day showing up to
get his daughter from the past to drink
the kool-aid so that she could resurrect
him in the future like we saw happen at
the beginning of the season on
legends of tomorrow and I think the fact
that they're not able to change time is
an important message for the season
usually you find that they're not able
to affect time the way that you think
they would and I think it's a bit of a
hat tip for what's happening during
vixen and kuwasa storyline like who
bosses big sticking point is that vixen
won't go back in time to change history
so that her family doesn't get fractured
vixen doesn't die her mother doesn't die
but if the legends weren't able to
prevent Nora from turning evil and going
with damien darhk's people then they're
probably not going to be able to change
time for vixens family either
number three Mallis calls re one of the
six and it sounds like one of the six
people they can either help him or hurt
him she has some power that can affect
him it probably has something to do with
her totem avatar the last airbender
style we know about a couple of the
todos because Ari and vixen both wield
totems so it sounds like there'll be a
couple people on the TV show that
they'll either redeem because they're
evil right now in working with damian
darhk-- or they're part of the legends
team that will be able to work together
to use all their totems to bind Mallis
and banish him to whatever realm that he
comes from so remember that we see an
old version of Nora she's not that bad
of a person but she's evil in
present-day so maybe there's a chance
that they could bring her back from the
dark side
same thing with Casas character she says
that she's gonna get vixen a chance to
try and help her out don't you
disappoint me so just hold your breath
or open up a tab in chrome for those
evil characters that possess totems
helping the legends bind Mallis by the
end of the season number 2 Earth X
Captain cold leaves the Waverider at the
end of the episode he says see you
around to heatwave but I took that to
mean that when they eventually bring
Captain Cold back in a future season or
whenever it'll be this version of the
character not the original version that
we saw in the flash of course number one
WTF is Constantine teasing the Sarah's
eventually going to succumb to the
darkness Mullis inside her she'll be
just like Nora with those red eyes just
fully possessed Rey better keep that
anti magic gun around in case he needs
to neutralize her in a really easy way
before they figure out how all the
totems work together and I referenced
Avatar The Last Airbender earlier I have
a feeling that when they bring all the
totems together it will unlock like an
avatar type stage something that's way
more powerful than any of the one totems
by itself so when constantine says they
need to figure their [ __ ]
they need to figure out how all the
totems work together but this was
episode 10 there are 18 episodes total
wally west is coming back in episode 12
episode 11 next week is going to be a
Groundhog's Day episode and then pretty
much the rest of the season is all wally
west but just let me know in the
comments if you spotted any Easter eggs
that I didn't mention during the video
most of the references they made to
Astra was from the constantine season
one that aired on NBC they talked about
the girl that he failed to say so there
was a lot of Constantine dialogue where
he's like hey remember when I did this
remember when I did that for all the
stuff that he did on that NBC show as
well as when he guest-starred on arrow
season 4 but ever since I've been
posting these Constantine videos people
have been asking about the katana mask
behind them on the Waverider here that's
from the arrow character she was on
arrow season 3 so it's her version of
katana is not the movie version of
katanas mask if you're a big Stanley
Kubrick fan the room that Nora was in
inside the insane asylum was room 237
that's the name of a movie that's a
documentary about all the theories of
the subtext of The Shining movie that
Stanley Kubrick made so that was just
sort of their way of invoking all this
crazy mystical nightmarish stuff that's
going on in Constantine's world but
there is a new round of that blast ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video congratulations to the winner
from my last video burnt toast gaming
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll name a new
winner when I post new flash that'll
probably be tomorrow but there was a
really cool Avenger stuff that happened
in the Marvel Universe so I'll do a
video for that tomorrow too so new
infinity war new flash stuff posting
tomorrow click here for brand new flash
and click here for my new Black Panther
infinity war trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight